er hat zwischen dieser ersten äußerung
von katrin göring eckardt
fraktionsvorsitzender der bündnisgrünen
und dem dementi da lagen nur wenige
stunden
es war also offenbar nicht abgesprochen
innerhalb der koalition dass eine
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
eingeführt werden soll das jedenfalls
noch nicht das alles spricht nicht
unbedingt für kommunikation und
einigkeit bei denen sich jetzt bei der
sich jetzt bildenden ampel kondition und
damit herzlich willkommen bei uns meine
gäste zunächst hier im studio ist
cerstin gammelin stellvertretende
leiterin des parlaments büro der
süddeutschen zeitung robin alexander ist
bei uns stellvertretender chefredakteur
der welt gruppe zu den tageszeitungen
wie die welt oder auch die welt am
sonntag gehören zugeschaltet sind
professorin ulrike ackermann
politikwissenschaftlerin und gründerin
sowie direktorin des john stuart mill
instituts für freiheits forschung in
heidelberg und schließlich der
politikwissenschaftler professor lothar
probst
programmieren wenn es zum
ampelbündnis kommt alles spricht eher
dafür dann eher weniger aus inhaltliche
übereinstimmung als wegen der
alternativlosigkeit zu diesem bündnis
naja ich denke es beides was dazu
beiträgt bisher ist das bemerkenswerte
das jedenfalls die zeitpläne alle
eingehalten werden ja also das ist
wirklich dem daten gesetz werden und da
wird auch geliefert das ist schon
ziemlich verwunderlich dass sagt aber
noch lange nichts darüber aus ob es bei
den inhalten auch ob man da zueinander
findet und ich glaube schon gerade das
bei den themen corona wie wir sehen die
debatte um eine impfpflicht aber auch
beim klima und auch bei den finanzen
noch einiges offen ist also das wird man
sehen dass verwunderlich ist einfach
dass trotzdem der optimismus sehr großes
dass anfang nächster woche dann der
koalitionsvertrag vorgestellt werden
kann jetzt haben da eine menage a trois
die ist immer kompliziert
ist der versuch einer ampel koalition
die jetzt zu bilden trotz aller guten
vorsätze eine quadratur des kreises
nein das glaube ich nicht im gegenteil
die haben ja wie die kollegin schon
sagte
zügig ihre eigenen widersprüche
bearbeitet was nur aus dem blick geraten
das ist die realität weil der zeitplan
der ampel ist deren eigener zeitplan
aber derzeit plant der korona pandemie
ist ein anderer also in der groner
pandemie wir zu spät entschieden da ist
die sind die nicht auf der höhe und das
ist auch ihre verantwortung weil das hat
die ampel der geschäftsführende
bundesregierung ziemlich dreist aus der
hand genommen hat gesagt wir sind hier
die parlamentarische mehrheit das ist
das erste was wir entscheiden jetzt
müssen sie das eigene nachbessern
wesentliches wollen sie noch einmal
nachliefern sie haben eine
ministerpräsidenten-konferenz zwei
wochen verzögert jetzt sollen sie doch
stattfinden also da ist die ampel
einfach nicht still scheitert nicht an
sich selbst aber es ist nicht auf der
höhe der herausforderung frage kann man
corona klima wirtschaft immer geht es
auch um freiheit und verantwortung
freiheit ist ja ihr großes thema ich
habe es gerade bei der vorstellung schon
gesagt kann denn dieses prinzip freiheit
und verantwortung kann dass die
zukünftige koalition leben natürlich
aber man kann natürlich nicht nur
demokratie theoretische freiheits
prinzipien herunterbeten und versuchen
die durchzusetzen sondern man muss einen
weg finden pragmatisch mit diesen
freiheits ansprüchen an diesen am new
orleans konflikten umzugehen und gerade
die korona krise jetzt fast zwei jahre
während die hat uns ja gelehrt wie
ambivalenz konflikte tatsächlich
aussehen dh die grenze die individuelle
freiheits grenze die freiheit die grenze
der individuellen freiheit die hört da
auf wo der schaden und die freiheit der
anderen beginnen und genau darum geht es
also wenn wir jetzt hier über maßnahmen
sprechen kann es nicht darum gehen dass
gegen das gemeinwohl und sozusagen in
absehen vom schadens prinzip einfach als
fakten rechte dahin gesetzt werden der
propst das leben wäre für politikerinnen
und politiker so schön wenn es nicht die
parteibasis gebe in allen drei parteien
muss die parteibasis ja dem
koalitionsvertrag zustimmen diese basis
ist wahrscheinlich auch in allen drei
parteien sie ist aufmüpfig sie ist
wählerisch leicht erregbar ist ja auch
vernünftig
ja das wird man sehen auf jeden fall
wissen ja alle drei parteien das letzten
endes die parteibasis oder aber
zumindest parteitage bei den grünen
sogar die mitglieder einen möglichen
koalitionsvertrag zustimmen müssen und
das ist natürlich auch schon eine würde
man merkt es ja an den reaktionen der
grünen sie haben den eindruck dass sie
sich bisher in der öffentlichkeit unter
wert verkauft haben in den bisherigen
gesprächen und sie merken dem druck der
basis auch der bewegung verhältnis von
futures unzufrieden und deshalb sind sie
natürlich derjenige der oder die partei
innerhalb der koalition die jetzt darauf
achtet dass sie nicht zu kurz kommt bei
den koalitionsverhandlungen und so kann
man auch die einlassung von erkennen
heute verstehen der ja gesagt hat also
es gibt immer noch viel zu tun nach
außen erscheint die bisherigen
erscheinen die bisherigen und niemals
friede freude eierkuchen aber hinter den
kulissen knirscht es glaube ich ganz
schön also michael kellner war da jetzt
angesprochen der bundesgeschäftsführer
der grünen heute bei den statements
während der generalsekretär der spd und
auch volker wissing der genauso wie der
fdp also ein bisschen er selbstbewusst
klingt weil er gelassen hat man ihm hat
man keller schon angemerkt dass er
möglicherweise doch etwas kritischer das
alles sieht in der körpersprache im
tonfall stimme etwas belegt er
möglicherweise nicht so ganz zufrieden
mit dem was da heute präsentiert wurde
in diesem kurzen statements vor der
landesvertretung rheinland-pfalz war das
auch so ein hinweis über die
befindlichkeit der 3 naja ich denke das
ist es auch ein doppeltes problem für
die grünen das eine ist ja gerade schon
angesprochen worden das ist natürlich so
dass klimapolitik der am
herzensangelegenheit ist dafür wurden
sie vor allen dingen gewählt und
deswegen sind eben jetzt viele junge
zweites verfügte aber auch älter also
alle die klimaschutz umsetzen wollen
guck mal auf die grünen und gucken nicht
auf die ampel gucken nicht auf die fdp
oder die spd das ist dann schon mal für
die grünen ist eine blöde situation wenn
eben nicht 100% beliefert werden kann
das andere problem aber ist glaube ich
intern bei den grünen das zwischen
harburg das habe klage gegen das werk
locker da gab es heute auch schon wieder
ja ich will mal sagen meldungen wonach
eben auch die frage ist wer soll ist das
klima ministerium übernehmen soll habe
ich das mache berbalk das machen und das
wird so ein bisschen wie eine heiße
kartoffel hin und her gegeben weil
derjenige der das klima ministerium hat
natürlich am ende auch den schwarzen
peter handel und das ist so das doppelte
problem der grün was irgendwie noch bis
zum wochenende gelöst werden muss wie
gesagt dass er mir gerade gesagt der
lackmustest von regierungshandeln jetzt
in bezug auf kroner der ist nicht so
richtig gelungen nachdem man jetzt schon
mal angefangen hat eigentlich schon zu
regieren mit der parlamentsmehrheit
liegt das aber vielleicht auch daran
dass man eben hinter verschlossenen
türen weiß nicht so genau was da alles
passiert eben doch noch viele fragen
ungeklärt sind und in manchen bereichen
die fronten auch noch ziemlich verhärtet
aber dafür ist gerade kein beispiel weil
da waren sie sich einig und sind schnell
raus gegangen und das ist sowieso also
wenn wir alte koalitionsverhandlungen
denken der letzte koalitionsvertrag von
angela merkel war ungefähr 70 prozent
spd 20 prozent csu und die leute von der
cdu habe das gelesen gesagt eure
internet dass wir noch das kanzler abend
gerettet haben so und dann waren die
zwei wochen sauer und das war vergessen
und die legislaturperiode wurde von
anderen dingen geprägt das heißt viel
wichtiger als ob die sich da jetzt
verstehen und werde wo es ist ist das
eine regierung die auf die krisen
reagiert und da steht zu befürchten dass
das heftige krisen werden weil brunner
ist heftiger zurück als viele dachten
als ich auch dachte was gerade an der
russisch polnischen grenze passiert ist
eine internationale krise von riesen
dimension und das bearbeitet jetzt
angela merkel noch mal so auf ihren
letzten tage wir dafür
erstaunlicherweise aus den der werbenden
ampel kritisiert also die frage ist ob
die ampel eine gute regierung wird
selbst wenn sie sich einigen
probst die
diese diese krisensituation heißt ja
dass zwei parteien jetzt in der
künftigen bundesregierung der koalition
sind die eben keine regierungserfahrung
haben
macht dass das was robin alexander da
gerade geschildert hat jetzt besonders
schwierig dass sie eben diesen wechsel
von der opposition in die
regierungsverantwortung vom wahlkampf in
den regierungsalltag nicht noch nicht so
richtig verinnerlicht hat nicht so
richtig hinbekommt
naja regierungserfahrung haben schon
beide nur die liegen schon etwas länger
zurück also insofern ist der eintritt in
eine ampel regierung natürlich nicht
ganz so einfach aber ich glaube wir
wissen ja aus der forschung wie solche
bündnisse ticken und wir haben aber
bisher wenig erfahrung mit dreier
koalitionen natürlich sind ja letzten
endes auch die koalition die wir bisher
an dreier-koalition wenn man die csu mal
als sehr eigenständige partei betrachtet
aber das ist trotzdem etwas anderes als
wenn drei sehr unterschiedliche partner
und davon noch zwei jedoch in vielen
vorstellungen ziemlich diametrale
unterschiede aufweisen wenn die
zusammenkommen sollen und von daher ist
es natürlich so dass diese neuen
erfahrungen erst mal aufgearbeitet
werden müssen die so eine
dreier-koalition funktionieren kann und
der alexander hat vollkommen recht dass
es nur funktionieren kann wenn man auf
krisen vorbereitet wird das heißt alles
was wir wissen bisher über koalition ist
dass es ein strategisches zentrum sein
ergeben muss und das müssen die
führenden vertreter innerhalb dieser
parteien sollen dazu gehören auch die
fraktionsvorsitzenden möglicherweise
aber auch die handelnden akteure am
regierungstisch die müssen sozusagen
immer im krisenmodus in der lage sein
auch schnell krisen zu bereinigen und
das muss untereinander funktionieren das
heißt wichtiger als koalitionsverträge
ist nachher die chemie zwischen den
handelnden personen davon hängt häufig
viel mehr ab als auch von dem was auf
das papier vielleicht auf 120 oder 130
seiten gebracht wird da kann man jetzt
überrascht ja schon etwas das die neuen
koalitionäre vom krisenmodus etwas
überrascht zu sein scheinen wir haben
diese krise seit fast zwei jahren da gab
es ja jetzt auch im zuge der der der
wahl und der neubildung einer
bundesregierung ja ein großes freiheits
versprechen vor allen dingen auch von
der fdp
diese
epidemischen notlage von nationaler
tragweite zurück zu fahren das war
eigentlich auch ein großes freiheits
versprechen das ist aber nicht so
richtig eingelöst werden kann
möglicherweise muss man sogar wieder in
einen teil lockdown oder einen richtigen
locker und zurückkehren was macht das
eigentlich auch mit den menschen die da
möglicherweise auch gerade die wähler
der fdp ja da ganz andere hoffnungen in
die partei gesetzt haben ich denke was
die korona krise an lang die
einschätzung der korona krise hat die
fdp schon länger falsch gelegen
in der weise natürlich haben wir einen
unglaublichen patentierung schub gehabt
innerhalb dieser corona krise der staat
ist in vielen punkten übergriffe
geworden das sind zum teil maßnahmen
gewesen die sich widersprochen haben sie
waren nicht durchdacht gut das ist die
bisherige alte regierung gewesen aber
das ist zum teil ein politik und und
administrations versagen gewesen man
kann sich nur wundern dass die dass die
bürger und bürgerinnen bisher da so so
so geduldig auf alles reagiert haben die
gesundheitsämter sind immer noch nicht
digitalisiert und so weiter und so fort
also man hätte innerhalb der fast zwei
jahre währenden krise diverses machen
können und vor allen dingen die neuen
koalitionäre hätten sich wirklich schöne
strichlisten machen können was lernen
wir aus den fehlern dieser bisherigen
regierung und dann haben sie jetzt die
ganze zeit geschwiegen und bei der fdp
hatte ich den eindruck dass sie
tatsächlich in politik
seminar manier bestimmte prinzipien
hochgehalten hat natürlich ist es
wichtig die individuelle freiheit zu
verteidigen gegenüber staatlichen
übergriffen und rechtsstaatliche
prinzipien einzuhalten
es ist auch wichtig dass das parlament
anders einbezogen werden muss als das
was ist also wie es wie es zum teil in
den letzten monaten gelaufen ist das ist
völlig richtig
aber
da
impfzwang zb völlig auszuschließen bzw
wenn von impfen die rede ist von von
staatlichem zwang zu reden das fand ich
also nicht nicht sonderlich klug
vereinigen haben wir ja beobachten
können was seit wochen in den
nachbarländern läuft und das sind keine
diktaturen in frankreich haben wir
andere impfquoten wir haben in italien
andere ebenen knoten quoten wir haben in
spanien andere impfquoten portugal und
so weiter und so fort ich verstehe nicht
dass man völlig schlafwandlerisch nur
die koalitionsverhandlungen macht und
überhaupt keine signale gegeben hat in
den letzten 12 wochen was dazu erwarten
jetzt hat man allerdings hat die
möglichkeit oder wo es gleich dazu sagen
dass in italien frankreich ich glaub ich
auch in spanien politische maßnahmen
auch leichter durchzusetzen sind
aufgrund des politischen systems und ist
der föderalismus nicht so ausgeprägt na
ja gut aber es gibt auch frankreich geld
westen nochmals stichworten es gibt da
eine große
natürlich auch die entsprechende
politische macht und er hat sie auch
durchgesetzt
was wir jetzt über den koalitionsvertrag
hier schon der sendung gesagt
unterschieden so ein bisschen schlimmer
da so ein bisschen durch papier ist
geduldig jetzt aber glaube ich gerade
ihr den grünen die unglaublich viel
fixieren wollen in diesem
koalitionsvertrag die haben ja schon mit
olaf scholz nicht unbedingt positive
erfahrungen in hamburg gemacht da haben
die hamburger grünen den tipp gegeben
lasst euch das alles schriftlich
versichern so eine art politischer
vollkasko tarif der waffe abschied
werden soll welchen sinn macht das dann
wenn das alles zu sagen in stein
gemeißelt ist und dann soll man politik
machen und die politik die ereignisse
sind wir jetzt gerade an der aktualität
auf verschiedenen politikfeldern die
hatten sich eben nicht an abmachungen
des koalitionsvertrags ja ich glaube
also scholz hat auch gestern noch mal
gesagt er hätte es kann das auf drei
seiten mal ein bisschen aufgeschrieben
was man so machen will und ist gut klar
man kann verstehen dass die grünen das
ausführlich machen wollen nach den
erfahrungen in hamburg aber es wurde
jetzt in der runde auch schon gesagt der
koalitionsvertrag ist ja im prinzip
zusammenfinden
vertrauensbasis schaffen für drei
parteien die sehr unterschiedlich sind
und die vertrauensbasis muss so gut sein
dass sie daneben bei corona krise
belarus krise was russlandkrise und so
weiter war es eben möglicherweise alles
noch kommt dass sie da vernünftig
zusammenarbeiten könne und ich glaube
der der koalition trag ist vor allen
dingen so eine art blaupause zu zeigen
leute wir können hier miteinander und
wir werden das schaffen ob das jetzt
alles 11 abgearbeitet wird wage ich dann
auch zu bezweifeln aber ohne
koalitionsvertrag gibt ja auch die ampel
nicht also deswegen ist er so eine pre
kondition sozusagen es war olaf scholz
wir wissen was er gestern gemacht hat er
war der süddeutschen zeitung auf dem
wirtschaftsgipfel genießen aber
ansonsten robin alexander glänzte durch
abwesenheit taucht oft ab ist das will
jetzt erst mal gucken was da passiert
wie das sich raushalten ist da taktik
ist das strategie dahinter hat er sich
da ein schweigegelübde in der
öffentlichkeit auferlegt und sagt wir
haben ja die verhandler in den
verschiedenen arbeitsgruppen also so
ganz richtig präsent ist olaf scholz ja
nicht er hat sich zur oma geäußert
letzte woche bundestag mit
verschwurbelten merkel setzen muss man
ja sagen wie ist diese rolle von von
olaf scholz da einschätzen ich glaube
dass er sich zwei dinge vorgenommen hat
in seiner kanzlei kommunikation das eine
ist nur sprechen wenn man was zu sagen
hat das noch klug und das andere ist
tatsächlich die fortschreibung der
merkel kommunikation dieses sehr sehr
lange schweigen und zögern solange man
nicht weiß wie die würfel jetzt fallen
und wirklich den entscheidung reifen zu
lassen und manchmal denkt man auch was
greift da eigentlich oder reif so ein
bisschen länger und da ist die frage ob
das so weitergeht weil wir in der doch
in anderen zeiten leben und ich finde es
schon erstaunlich wir haben die pandemie
und da ringen eigentlich zwei prinzipien
miteinander und zwar prinzipien der
bearbeitung der pandemie das einmal
diese alte ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
eine überhaupt nicht im grundgesetz
vorgesehene runde ein merkel die sein wo
es gute gründe gibt nicht mehr so weiter
zu machen weil das ja überhaupt nicht
erfolgreich war zum schluss und dann
gibt es diese fdp idee wir verlagen hat
das zurück ins parlament wir treffen die
wesentlichen entscheidungen im bundestag
jetzt machen wir aber gerade beides
jetzt gibt es am donnerstag ein neues
gesetz und anschließend tag die mpk und
das ist nicht gut da hätte man sich auf
einen verständigen sollen ähnliches gilt
bei belarus ich meine die kanzlerin
telefoniert gestern mit lukaschenko
einbruch unserer bisherigen außenpolitik
bis haben wir gesagt wir werden dem
nicht auf wir kennen den nicht an da mag
es gute gründe für geben aber heute
kritisiert sie auch mit nouripour
führender grüner außenpolitiker dafür
und das ist nicht gut das gab es auch
früher nicht also in diesem zwischen
phasen der koalition entstand kein
interregnum wie mittelalter sondern die
arbeiteten zusammen ein beispiel als
helmut kohl abgewählt wurde schröder und
fischer kam und damals war die kosovo
krise ganz wichtig da haben die alles
abgesprochen das ging bis zu einer
gemeinsamen kabinettssitzung die zeigen
wollten in so einer frage ist die
deutsche politik 1 und sowohl die
pandemie als auch die belarus frage sind
solche fragen und da muss olaf scholz
mit merkel zusammen stehen und da kann
ja nicht schweigen und andeutung bei der
süddeutschen zeitung weil man ja gut
dann merkt ja offensichtlich kooperieren
beide behaupten das jedenfalls von
angela merkel haben ja sogar gesagt sie
könne nachts ruhig schlafen wenn jetzt
olaf scholz dem nächsten kanzleramtes
ehe ich glaube das problem ist einfach
wenn er schon jetzt raus gehen würde und
sie mit merkel so abstimmt ja das dann
herr linder und frau werber und habe
sagen würden ja hallo und wir also das
ist ja gerade die crux dass das sieht
man auch dass die 30 nicht nur noch
nicht einig sind weil er scholz ja
eigentlich gar nicht das mandat hat
jetzt zu verhandeln alleine mit der
marke neuerungen im historischen
beispielen so bleiben wenn beim kosovo
joschka fischer die damals noch halb
pazifistischen grünen bei einer stange
halten kann dann wird doch er habe oder
frau habe pulver belarus bei der stange
halten also das ist eine führung die ich
schon von leute erwartet die
bundesregierung machen geht um die frage
für ackermann und die frage wieso die
alte bundesregierung die neue nicht
übergangsweise zusammenarbeiten wie
dafür eigentlich auch von der verfassung
vorgesehen ist die kann sondern ist ja
so lange im amt bis zu der sekunde bis
der neue bundeskanzler vom bundestag mit
mehrheit gewählt ist das ist ja so
vorgesehen in der tat hat es 198
offensichtlich ganz gut geklappt woran
liegt das dass es dieses mal diese
missverständnisse gibt liegt es an den
personen oder liegt dass er den äußeren
umständen
das liegt daran dass man sich nach weder
herr scholz nach frau merkel noch die
neue koalition klare außenpolitische
vorstellungen hat also wir haben alle in
erinnerung dass außenpolitik in dem
wahlkampf überhaupt kanada rolle spielte
es ist doch auffällig dass sich kein
mensch um den job des außenministers
soll der aus ministerin schlägt also man
hat den eindruck man will hier politik
machen schön abgeschottet von der welt
sich ums klima kümmern da kümmert man
sich aber auch nicht so richtig druck
das nun eigentlich indien und china was
ganz anderes machen und alles mögliche
vereiteln was wir hier an großen
beschlüsse fassen und so weiter und so
fort also man hat den eindruck selbst
vergessen wird da vor sich hin
verhandelt und man hat keine klaren
vorstellungen also ich denke es ist kein
zufall dass bisher nirgends spekuliert
wird wer wird denn tatsächlich aus mir
werden rechtes machen frau baerbock hat
da möglicherweise ambitionen aber ob sie
nur wirklich die geeignete person es in
dieser in dieser schwierigen
weltpolitischen lage einer neuen
weltordnung mit diesen karten mit diesen
krisen mit dieser migrations krise die
uns wieder ins haus steht und fast
kriegsähnlichen zuständen an der
polnische ukraine spiele russischen
grenze habe ich bezweifle ob sie ob sie
da nicht völlig überfordert wäre und
dass diese unstimmigkeiten und dieses
knirschen jetzt zu beobachten ist
zwischen merkel und scholz ist auch
ausdruck davon dass das sehr sehr unklar
ist in der neuen koalition nur noch bei
der außen und sicherheitspolitik bleiben
probst es könnte sich diese situation ja
in osteuropa noch weiter eskalieren
stichwort putin in russland auch da wird
ja befürchtet dass möglicherweise sogar
zu einer ausweitung des konfliktes kommt
in dieser gegend einbeziehung der
ukraine wollen sich zu sehr spekulieren
aber wenn sich diese situation zuspitzt
dann spitzt sich ja auch hier bei uns
die situation zu wenn es diese
geregelten diesen geregelten übergang
von einer regierung merkel zu einer
regierung stolz offensichtlich nicht
gibt oder jedenfalls ziemlich holprig
über die bühne geht
ja ich möchte zunächst einmal auf einen
umstand hinweisen der mir zu wenig
beleuchtet wird wir haben eine
geschäftsführende regierung
bundesregierung da gibt es ein
vizekanzler der ist scholz und es gibt
eine kanzlerin merkel das heißt die spd
ist ja sozusagen der kontinuität
zwischen der alten und der neuen
regierung also kann sie macht sich ja
jetzt häufig sohn schlanken fuß auch
herr scholz in dem er wie gesagt und so
tut als wäre er gar nicht mehr mitglied
dieser regierung das kann man ihm einzig
ja gar nicht durchgehen lassen das heißt
wir haben gar kein vakuum sondern es
wäre durchaus möglich über die
geschäftsführende regierung diese
verbindung zwischen der ampel der
zukünftigen ampel wenn sie denn zustande
kommt und der jetzigen regierung
herzustellen und das wird personifiziert
im und durch olaf scholz dass das nicht
passiert zeigt dass sich die spd
sozusagen schon heimlich davon spielt
aus der alten regierung und zu neuen
ufern ausbricht dass sie damit aber ihre
historischen wollen ihrer verantwortung
nicht wirklich gerecht wird das heißt
wenn wir jetzt konflikte haben die
kurzfristig gelöst werden müssen also
kampf gegen die pandemie aber auch die
frage wie migration ist ja aber jetzt
schon erwähnt wird in der sendung dass
dann möglicherweise auch auf der
europäischen ebene sehr schnell
gehandelt werden muss kompetent
gehandelt werden muss auch in der
absprache der noch amtierenden kanzlerin
die sich daher
lege er große erfahrung hat und dem
neuen kanzler der ja schon auch in der
bundesregierung seit einer reihe von
jahren ist
das sind die kurzfristigen entscheidung
aber die längerfristigen so sieht man
beim thema klima da muss ja auch eine
entscheidung jetzt im koalitionsvertrag
wie soll das qualifiziert werden was
muss da rein was in die nächsten
maßnahmen gartner aber das gefühl dass
da auch noch fast noch mehr gestritten
wird ist der streit jetzt gerade in
bezug auf klima sieht auf das thema
klima sozusagen fast das prägende
element einer kommenden ampel koalition
die noch in schweres fahrwasser geraten
kann also das gut dass er jetzt sagen
dass eine kommende ampelkoalition weil
fakt ist wir haben noch keine
ampelkoalition fakt ist die haben noch
keine gemeinsame basis auf der sie
handeln können und die haben mich über
laufstege wissen sie jetzt herstellen
und zwar ganz schnell von daher ist ein
schneller zeitplan eigentlich ganz okay
weil man sagt wir haben jetzt wirklich
dringende sache irgendwie hier dann muss
es schnell gehen das ist richtig aber es
ist noch nicht passiert also ich glaube
und ich glaube auch dass die das
fdp und grüne schon ein bisschen komisch
gucken würden wir stolz ist immer raus
geht jeden tag und sagt und das machen
wir so und das machen wir so also das
mal vorausgeschickt ich glaube schon
dass das klima thema mit den finanzen
zusammen und ich denke eigentlich auch
der außen und europapolitik die
entscheidenden themen sein müssen und
bis jetzt gibt es irgendwie keine
anzeichen darauf dass es da schon eine
einigung gibt also wir haben dieses
papier der ag finanzen jetzt mal gehabt
ehrlich gesagt ist eine einzige
enttäuschung sehr viel farbig
gekennzeichnet gelb sind sätze
hinterlegt die die fdp eingebracht hat
die die anderen nicht wollen grün sind
die von den grünen und so weiter und das
sieht man ein sehr buntes papier und das
bedeutet eben das ist nicht viel geeint
und ganz in die großen projekte waren
noch gar nicht drin und deswegen glaube
ich schon dass jetzt heute nacht und die
nächsten tagen noch einiges zu tun sein
wird und ohne klima und ohne auch dieses
vetorecht glaube ich für klima
entscheidungen wird es den grün sehr
schwer fallen daran zu gehen gab es da
auch vor allen dingen von seiten der
grünen aber auch der fdp zu gerade beim
thema klima zu viele
vorfestlegungen hat man da zu viele rote
linien gezogen die man auf keinen fall
überschreiten darf sonst kann es bei den
eigenen leuten nicht durch ist da schon
trotz dieses schweigegelübde ist dass
ich ja manche da auferlegt haben zuviel
schon in die öffentlichkeit gekommen als
dass man hinter diese position jetzt
nicht mehr so richtig zurückkamen die
kommunikationsdisziplinen den
verhandlungen hat ja nun wirklich
gestimmt ich glaube die grünen werden
opfer ihres wahlkampfes weil wenn man im
wahlkampf sagt wir sind die letzte
regierung die noch irgendetwas
sinnvolles tun kann und fotos mit
sterbenden wäldern auf
aufnimmt und auf marktplätzen den
eindruck erweckt wenn ihr uns nicht
wählt kommt die apokalypse dann ist
natürlich ziemlich schwierig kompromisse
zu verkaufen aber da sind die grünen ein
bisschen das opfer ihrer eigenen
rhetorik und ihres eigenen wahlkampfs
geworden prozess könnte man ja bei der
spd oder bei der fdp auch sagen in
sachen finanzen oder sozialpolitik ist
ja auch viel versprochen worden was man
möglicherweise nicht halten kann in
einer kombination gerade mit
mit den beiden anderen parteien holt der
wahlkampf auch die anderen parteien
jetzt ein und wird es da am ende wenn
dieser koalitionsvertrag wie geplant
nächste woche präsentiert wird auch viel
enttäuschung und viel ärgerlicher
wenn man es salopp formulieren wollte
konnte man uns daher sagen alle drei
parteien sind ja im grunde zum erfolg
und zur einigung verdanken denn keine
könnte zum jetzigen zeitpunkt mehr ohne
dass sie riskiert dafür abgestraft zu
werden aussteigen die spd will unbedingt
das kanzleramt die grünen wollen auch in
die regierung gibt die people in die
regierung
und man hat an den
sondierungsverhandlungen der
gescheiterten jamaika-koalition oder der
sondierung für jamaika gesehen was
passiert wenn eine partei in wirft das
könnte sich die fdp kein zweites mal
erlauben und die grünen haben gesehen
welche schicksal blühen würde wenn sie
hinschmeißen würden also das erst mal
vorausgesetzt kann man sagen dass jetzt
die grünen natürlich in der position
sind so sie nicht wollen dass sie den
klimarat in der regierung übernehmen sie
wollen keine arbeitsteilige regierung
sondern sie treten ja weiter mit dem
spruch an den sie auch in der im
wahlkampf im mund geführt haben nämlich
wir wollen eine klima region also frau
berg wo es immer wieder bei jedem
statement und die fdp wiederum will
zeigen dass sie ihre versprechungen
einhält gegenüber in ihrer basis
gegenüber den wählerinnen und wähler
denn keine steuererhöhungen
steuersenkungen hat sie zwar nicht
durchgesetzt sie verkauft jetzt als
erfolg lassen es keine steuererhöhungen
geben und die spd wäre natürlich ihr
soziales profil entwickeln herhalten
unternimmt ja jetzt versuche mit neuen
gesetzes entwürfen er hat ja auch schon
die handschrift der alten regierung sehr
stark durch seine gesetzentwürfe geprägt
also jede partei versucht auf ihrem
terrain punkte zu machen und es darauf
angewiesen dass das in irgendeiner art
und weise im koalitionsvertrag
unterkommen ich habe es war vorhin
gesagt koalitionsverträge sind geduldig
ist papier aber sie haben natürlich
trotzdem eine bedeutung als
selbstvergewisserung und das ist ja
gewissermaßen die geschäftsgrundlage
einer regierung dass das immer
durcheinander gewürfelt werden kann
durch themen die man gar nicht übersieht
oder durch krisen sei eine andere frage
trotzdem braucht man natürlich so etwas
und wir wissen aus der koalitions
forschung das immer parteien versuchen
möglichst konkret festzuhalten was sie
in einer legislaturperiode durchsetzen
wollen dass die grünen jetzt besonders
darauf basis verständlich weil sie in
der tat die sorge haben dass sie von der
spd und möglicherweise auch von der fdp
gerade wenn der das ressort das
finanzressort lindner geht über den
tisch gezogen werden also sozusagen
allerhand was zu verlieren und müssen
sehen wie sie ihr fell mit dem wort
klima regierung könnte ja möglicherweise
auch das binnenklima in der zukünftigen
koalition gemeint sein gerade wenn wir
noch moment beim klima bleiben wird
dieses thema auch zu sehr mit
erwartungen vielleicht sogar mit
symbolik überfrachtet also ich glaube
weil man es ernst nimmt kann man das
klima eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht mit
viel erwartungen überfrachten weil das
ist ja einfach dringend
und die klima regierung ich kann bewusst
den grünen darum geht es gar nicht so
dass sie alles machen wollen wo klima
ist sondern sie wollen eben gerade nicht
nur alleine in die haftung genommen
werden für alle themen die klima sind
also wenn sie die werbung immer redet
von der klima regierung spielt sie
natürlich auch auf an auf scholz' selber
klima kanzler auch
in der wahl also gepostet haben
sozusagen also die wollen ja dass die
fdp und die spd mit in die haftung
genommen werden fürs klima und das ist
dann nicht heißt okay das hat es nicht
geklappt mit dem kohleausstieg und mit
den erneuerbaren energien und das ist
nur wegen den grünen das ist dann
während sie ja im prinzip die einzigen
verlierer in so einer konstellation und
deswegen ist das für die so wichtig ich
denke aber schon dass das ein wichtiger
punkt ist die gefahr dieses dieses thema
unglaublich moralisch aufzuladen und zu
einem thema zu machen was alles andere
über wirkt also alle einen
gesellschaftlichen probleme alle anderen
krisen alle spaltungen mit denen wir
jetzt schon zu tun haben die natürlich
auch wenn diese klimapolitik sowie die
grünen sich das vorstellen eins zu eins
umgesetzt würde zu verwerfungen
innerhalb der gesellschaft führen wird
wir haben in frankreich das ja schon
beobachtet was mit den chinesen schon
passiert wir haben dann wir haben dann
probleme dass die spaltung zwischen
stadt und land weiter zunehmen wird und
so weiter und so fort also wenn hier vom
reißbrett eine moralische fundierte
klimapolitik durchgesetzt wird die nicht
rücksicht nimmt auf die sozialen folgen
dann kommen wir noch mehr in teufels
küche als wir sowieso schon sozusagen
drin sind und da habe ich richtig große
sorgen was diese koalition anlangt
die kinder mal auf das thema klima und
grüne insofern noch mal zurückkommen ist
den grünen denn das gelungen was sie ja
eigentlich vorhaben sich viel breiter
thematisch aufzustellen eben nicht nur
auf klima umwelt
frauenpolitik familienpolitik reduziert
zu werten sondern eben auch in bereichen
verteidigung innen finanzen zu zeigen
dass sie
kompetenzen haben und kompetenz
einbringen müssen ist das hat man das
sozusagen unter den zukünftigen
koalitionspartner und so wahrgenommen
wird das auch in der politischen
öffentlichkeit so wahrgenommen sind sie
da auf einem erfolgreichen weg selbst
wenn sie jetzt das
bundesfinanzministerium nicht bekommen
werden
prinzipiell sind die grünen da sehr viel
besser aufgestellt als früher waren und
auch besser als manche aus der
politischen konkurrenz die grünen haben
sehr kompetente fachpolitiker im bereich
verteidigung mittlerweile im bereich
innenpolitik da haben die wirklich
richtig substanz gewonnen in den letzten
jahren den versuch das aus zu spielen
haben sie aber nicht in den
koalitionsverhandlungen abgebrochen
sondern schon im wahlkampf das war ja
eigentlich die idee von robert habeck
die große linke neue volkspartei zu
werden ganz breit nicht nur
interessensgruppen nicht nur ein thema
das ist dann unter dem der kandidatur
von frau werbung schnell gescheitert
dramatisch gescheitert und dann hat man
sich
hatte kultureller regression wieder auf
das gestützt was man mal aus den 80ern
gelernt hatte und das fällt ihnen jetzt
natürlich auf die füße und deshalb wenn
es schlecht für die grünen läuft können
sie diese stärken die sie sich
eigentlich mühevoll und erfolgreich
gearbeitet haben jetzt nicht mehr
ausspielen das ist ja jetzt gerade die
frage nimmt herr habeck das oder wird er
fragen nach dem nach dem
innenministerium wenn das mit dem
finanzen jetzt sagen wir mal doch an
länder geht wie es aussieht wenn aber
der herr habig das innenministerium
nimmt und die frau berbalk vielleicht
eine präferenz für außen haben sollte
ist der klimaministerium mehr weg also
müsste dann frau berg doch das klima
ministerium nehmen und das ist ja so ein
bisschen jetzt die frage wer dieses
ministerium oder dieses transformations-
ministerium dann bekommen und überhaupt
haben will probst wäre es dann sogar
vielleicht sinnvoll dass die grünen auf
dieses klima umwelt energie ministerium
bewusst verzichten um eben diese
breitere politische aufstellung
hinzukriegen das geht ja jetzt nicht nur
um die nächsten vier jahre
die grünen wollen sich ja politisch
weiter entwickeln sie haben eine
zeitlang sogar von einer kanzlerin
partei geträumt ist das wichtig da
vielleicht auch ein stück weit von der
eigenen inhaltlichen politischen
vergangenheit abstand zu gewinnen
man kann natürlich nicht verkennen dass
die grünen nach wie vor in erster linie
aufgrund der umweltpolitik gewählt
werden das ist die höchste kompetenz zu
schreiben die sie vor allen anderen
parteien haben die kompetenz
zuschreibung in anderen politikfeldern
ist nach wie vor relativ gering trotzdem
haben sie natürlich darauf hat er
alexander ja schon zu recht hingewiesen
auch verbreitert sie haben nicht nur
gute fachpolitiker sie haben auch viel
getan programmatisch viel getan um sich
zu verbreitern also inhaltlich und
programmatisch zu verbreitern sie haben
einen wirtschaftsrat bei der fraktion
gegründet darunter sind vertreter großer
deutscher unternehmen aus der
chemieindustrie aus der autoindustrie
auch aus anderen bereichen also die
guten sind durchaus im dialog mit der
wirtschaft man kann ja auch klimapolitik
heute nicht nur als moralisierende
politik betreiben sondern die ist ja
verknüpfen mit vielen anderen fragen vor
allen dingen auch mit wirtschaft mit
innovationen mit zukunftsfähigkeit wir
haben das gerade in glasgow gesehen und
her gut terry unter anderen sind ja
alles keine moralapostel sondern es geht
schon darum so zu sagen hier eine
entscheidende wende in verschiedenen
bereichen herbeizuführen also die frage
ob die grünen sicher gefallen punkt wenn
sich jetzt nachdem klimaministerium
greifen mit dem vetorecht und so weiter
ist in der tat eine spannende frage
ähnliche frage stellt sich auch für die
fdp mit dem finanzministerium
man sagt ja häufig dass gerade die
parteien die eine bestimmte programmatik
kam häufig eine politik durchsetzen
können die vielleicht nicht gerade
beliebt ist also eher lindner müsste
möglicherweise
schulden machen oder schulden vertreten
wenn auch über umwege
ein klima von dem mann mit schulden
auflädt endlich wieder vom deutsche
einheit oder über die kfw als aufbau
gang und die grünen wiederum müssten
sozusagen in einem innenministerium zum
beispiel eine politik betreiben die die
migrationspolitik ganz anders
auf andere füße oder auf andere beine
gestellt als das bisher der fall gewesen
ist möglich aber es auch mit
schmerzhaften einschnitten für die grüne
basis team dieser hinsicht tatsächlich
hoch moralisch ist also insofern wäre es
wirklich eine spannende konstellation zu
sehen denn beide parteien ministerien
übernehmen die vielleicht nicht
unbedingt ihnen auf den leib geschnitten
sind das sind doch ist ihr wunsch was
den wunsch nach ministerium anlangt ist
auch auffällig die fdp möchte das
finanzministerium aber das
wirtschaftsministerium angesichts der
lage in der sich deutschland befindet
ist ja nun wäre ja ganz zentrales
ministerium auch das was uns da die
nächsten jahre erwartet auch als folge
der der korona krise aber den ganzen
umbrüchen weltweit und es noch einmal zu
sagen außenministerium und
wirtschaftsministerium darauf scheinen
nun gerade die die sich als großer
erneuerer hinstellen nicht scharf zu
sein also das sagt doch ein bisschen was
aus wie soll ich sagen über den
innovations- trieb diese diese neuen
koalition und ob da nicht ganz viel von
autosuggestion eigentlich auch die rede
sein muss wenn alle sprachen es wird neu
und ist der aufbruch und das ist die
große reform koalition also ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen bisher ist es mir
noch nicht so richtig über das außen und
das wirtschaftsministerium reist man
sich aber nicht unbedingt gerade es ist
ja eigentlich eher das innen- oder
freilich auch das finanzministerium was
lothar probst jetzt gar nicht gesagt hat
das wird in dem bereich in dem man
eigentlich sich
wohl fühlen müsste dann zu unpopulären
maßnahmen gezwungen wird aber dass die
eigene programmatik die eigene
überzeugung angeht wäre das
möglicherweise sogar ein ein
erfolgsrezept also habe ich als innen-
und lindner als finanzminister
möglicherweise schon also ich denke
schon dass herr lin das auch sicher
viele von den positionen mit denen er
reingegangen oder reingeht und so eine
koalition unter mit der fdp wird es das
nicht geben und das nicht geben und das
nicht geben das er dann sehr schnell
auch ins nachdenken kommen wird wenn er
in brüssel sitzt mit 27 finanzminister
wenn er bei g20 ist mit den großen
staaten dieser welt dann hört er auch
was anderes und ich glaube das wird bei
herrn lindner auch in großen land
prozess auslösen so ähnlich würde ich
das auch bei herrn h wegsehen aber ich
würde gern noch ein wort sagen zum
wirtschafts und zum aussenministerium
das sind in dem jetzigen zuschnitt zwar
sehr unattraktiv in ministerien weil die
europa und auch die aussenpolitik sehr
starken kanzleramt gemacht wird also ein
außenminister hamas also bei aller
wertschätzung aber wo waren die großen
projekte und das wirtschaftsministerium
herr altmaier ist ja schon fast
tragische figur also wenn man den
finanzminister und den
wirtschaftsminister gesehen hat möchte
man eigentlich lieber nur finanzminister
seien aber nicht wirtschaftsminister
weil so wie das jetzt zugeschnitten ist
die
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten in diesem
ministerium wirklich total eingeschränkt
sind das ist dass die zuständigkeit die
ressortzuständigkeit einfach auch neu
aufgestellt
werden muss indem man sagt also
das gibt ja verschiedene konstellationen
im einzelnen nicht durchgehend das
einfach diese klassische ressort
aufteilung sich überlebt also gerade
beim auswärtigen amt ist das seit jahren
überfällig das muss mit dem
entwicklungshilfeministerium
zusammengelegt werden wir haben einen
riesen diplomaten k die wahnsinnig viel
über die länder weiß deprimiert ist das
alles im kanzleramt gemacht wird wie in
anderen mysterium leute die mit richtig
richtig viel geld durch die lande ziehen
oder aber diese expertise nicht haben
das ist sowas von oft das ist auch in
england schon gemacht worden nur das
problem ist dann hat man halt einen
posten weniger zu verteilen und da man
jetzt einen partei mehr in koalition er
braucht man eigentlich ein paar mehr
posten zum verteilen aber wenn es nach
sachlage ginge wäre das am ersten tag
der koalitionsführung entschieden worden
das heißt die personelle frage von
ackermann muss ja jetzt auch noch
gestellt beziehungsweise beantwortet
werden in den verschiedenen ministerien
braucht man da tatsächlich eine
neuaufstellung also sie haben jetzt
gesagt außenministerium
wirtschaftsministerium da reißt sich
niemand darum wie muss man das aufwerten
denn wie gesagt die imposanten
ministerium sind die erinnern und und
finanzministerium ja aber deshalb hat
man den eindruck dass es tatsächlich um
angenehme und gute posten geht aber dass
das sachlichkeit prinzip bisher bei mir
noch nicht so richtig angekommen ist
angesichts der herausforderungen vor
denen wir stehen unmittelbar stehen aber
auch in den nächsten jahren stehen und
insofern bin ich sehr wohl der meinung
dass natürlich das außenministerium
aufgewertet werden muss und über herrn
mas brauchen wir kein wort zu verlieren
das war die größte katastrophe vor
außenpolitisch was wir uns sie erlaubt
haben aber das musste ich doch ändern ja
also es wird wenn wir keinen keine und
zwar gut besetzt und zwar mit personen
die es können und nicht nur die auch
parteiintern
gründen versorgt werden müssen sondern
dass es endlich auch um qualifikation
geht natürlich will jeder wähler partei
die eigenen leute unterbringen aber ich
denke wir sind noch weltweit und auch in
unserem unserem land in der lage dass es
nach qualifikation nachhaltigkeit und
nach persönlichkeiten auch gehen muss
und dann müssen wir halt eben noch mal
genauer hinschauen und auch schauen wer
da auf dem tableau überhaupt steht also
das was was das die letzte regierung in
dieser form so abgewählt worden ist lag
ja auch an diesen bescheiden personal
und den jobs die sie eben nicht gut
gemacht wird die herr probst die
qualifikation der zukünftige minister
dadurch möglicherweise erleichtert dass
die richtigen personen ins amt kommen
dass wir jetzt mit einer multiplen
krisensituation zu tun haben vielleicht
anders als 2005 als angela merkel
angefangen hat regierungschefin zu sein
und sich weiterzuentwickeln dass wir in
einer ganz anderen situation sind die
auch ganz andere antworten auf die
gegenwart und auf die nächste zukunft
erfordert
wir haben ja jetzt viel darüber geredet
es gibt mehrere fundamentalen
herausforderungen sowohl in der
innenpolitik in der klimapolitik aber
auch in der außenpolitik und natürlich
braucht man dazu das entsprechende
personal und man wird gespannt sein
können wie auf den verschiedenen posten
diese neue koalition dieses personen
karussell tatsächlich löst dass wir gar
nicht so einfach sein und ich gebe
natürlich allen recht die sagen wir
brauchen qualifizierte personen gerade
auch in der außenpolitik das ist enorm
wichtig angesichts der krisen die uns
bevorstehen und die sich am horizont
abzeichnen oder schon da sind und es ist
natürlich so dass die
personalfragen im grunde ja immer
mitschwingen bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen und
da findet jetzt das tauziehen hinter den
kulissen statt jeder versucht sich da
irgendwo zu profilieren und ob wir
nachher das personal bekommen was für
diese posten gleichen des kommen dagegen
wehrte ich nicht sagen aber es wäre in
der jetzigen situation natürlich enorm
wichtig nicht nur qualifizierte person
waren sondern auch personen die das in
die öffentlichkeit kommunizieren können
und den ernst der lage erkannt dann denn
ob das bonner politik ist außenpolitik
oder klimapolitik das sind dicke bretter
zu bohren sind von dieser regierung und
da darf man gespannt sein wie sie das
lösen jetzt leide ich würde was doch
wahnsinnig interessant wäre wenn die mit
der person eine idee verbinden würden
weil jetzt den einen grünen der dem
innenminister genau so macht wie vorher
die cdu da die spd dass wir doch nicht
spannend aber nehmen wir doch mal die
haben einen cem özdemir die haben einen
grünen realpolitiker mit
migrationshintergrund wir haben
islamkonferenz die man eine sehr gute
idee war aber seit zehn jahren
festgefahren ist es würde sich sofort
ändern wenn ein innenminister die
ansprechen würde der selber muslimischen
hintergrund hat oder nehmen wir die
große skepsis die in vielen
migrantischen familien ist seit dem ende
des gegen organe wie den
verfassungsschutz und anderen das würde
sich doch auf berechnen lassen wenn wir
da jemanden hätten der selber zu dieser
community gehörte also damit könnte man
eine idee verbinden die an die
wirklichen hätte ja nur sie scheinen ja
das gar nicht in erwägung zu ziehen und
das nach dem alten system aus würfeln zu
wollen dann lassen wir diesen appell
jetzt zum ende der sendung so stehen ich
bin eine sich bei kerstin gammelin bei
robin alexander arbeit unglücke
ackermann und bei lothar probst liebe
zuschauer morgen in der phoenix runde
jetzt spricht die basis kampf um den cdu
vorsitz morgen ist bewerbungsschluss für
die nachfolge von armin laschet und wir
werden uns mit diesem thema in der
phoenix runde beschäftigen dieses thema
wird allerdings heute abend schon bei
phoenix noch eine rolle spielen nämlich
bei phoenix der tag mit thomas pate
darin die pressekonferenz eines dieser
kandidaten nämlich friedrich merz der
zum dritten mal hintereinander sich um
den 10 vorsitz bewirbt bleiben sie bei
uns
[Musik]